[Applause]
thanks so much for coming by
it's my pleasure my pleasure man i
always watch the show i think you're
dying about you two belong together
really and quickly
i'm not gonna dynamite that's very nice
you to say
you know it's great to me it's amazing
uh you're 75 years old you're still
going strong that's an incredible thing
well not that strong but i'm going
i'm uh yeah you get 75 it's not a kid
anymore i guess
i mean i got no sex life i just told you
i'm at the age now if i squeeze into a
parking place i'm sexually satisfied
but i uh i got married again recently
too
i heard this three years ago i married a
lovely girl his name is joan she's from
utah and she's a mormon that's right i'm
woman you really you really married a
mormon that's right and i'm very happy
very happy in fact next week i'm
marrying her sister
i got my eye on her brother too
i don't want to hear about that i'm a
good woman i'll tell you that
i got a woman who loves me for my money
and my fame and not for what i am
ah i tell you before i got married for
years i was as they say you know just uh
playing a field oh yeah or to be more
accurate i was playing with myself in
the field
but you enjoyed that it was a joy yes i
enjoyed that
were you watching me yes rodney i was
yeah
he wants me to be their answering
service i'll do that
if you have a computer and someone calls
you and you're not home they'll hear me
say hi there's a ride in dangerfield
they're not home and i want to tell them
a joke
just if you have a computer tune around
to my site rodney.com and i'll show you
how i could be your answering service
okay
thank you very much everybody has a
computer that's what i want to say there
and what else is that you really ha you
really have a you have a website now
don't have a website yes i'm
doing very very well and uh it's
something i like to communicate with
people
by uh mentioning what i'm just doing and
you just don't seem like a website kind
of guy to me you just you know
my wife started it you know oh really
that's why i picked up on a nice supply
of the humor too and that's the way it
works
this is amazing because you've gotten to
a point now where you're in the computer
age but
you're starting out you know a number of
years ago you were really playing some
tough gigs you were this was a hard time
for you at the beginning yeah yeah i
worked
this is nice you can finish your act
without getting hit here you know
toughness that's not true actually yeah
really yeah
i worked in tough places places like
fonzo's knuckle room
aldos formerly vetoes formerly nunzio's
that was a tough one nunzu i sat down to
eat the menu that had broken leg of lamb
and nunzio he was tough nunzio he said
to me kid you want to go hunting i said
okay i'm game and he shot me
ah you're all right
shoulders is tough too i'll tell you
that what a rocket boy
i don't know what you go through with
shoulders you know sometimes you know i
think back of all the women i had to
sleep with to get where i got you know
[Laughter]
it's hell isn't it right it's gonna take
catch me live i'll be in las vegas
february 8th of the mgm
another plug what that all right it says
these things come up mention them right
now
you know what the heck well tell us
about this movie meet wally sparks uh
yeah why talk about that
i just you just plugged everything else
i thought you'd want to plug the movie
when you're plugging the website i
thought plug the movie as well so i'm
going over tonight as matter of fact to
do a show over at the
lincoln uh the lincoln sony theater sony
theater and i'll be here tomorrow night
too
so we're doing a little turn before the
movie goes on
and the movie is uh well every time you
make a movie you think you're making
going with the wind you know
and you're kidding yourself your
realization never lives up to the
anticipation
you know is that deep
you really sucked me in there rodney but
i'm uh
but people like this when they laugh at
it and uh i guarantee you'll have big
laughs
we got a uh we got a funny clip actually
not so do it over again
did you well he's a loud raucous
talk show host and uh he goes to this
party this big
lavish party from the governor's house
in georgia and he gets into
constant trouble and this is one of the
kind of troubles he gets into if you
want to watch this
all right let's take a look at this clip
from meet wally sparks take a look
what a party looks like the unhappy hour
hi you come here often don't worry honey
i'm not making a plate for you i don't
want this guy
oh i'm sorry
[Music]
hey governor how are you you don't know
how excited i am
the american theater is back
i uh i always wanted to do shakespeare
you're doing the classics now meet wally
sparks and of course uh at seven
tomorrow night at lincoln sony theaters
uh you'll be doing a live act to
premiere the movie that's right
very exciting to have you on thank you
very much thank you for joining us
ronnie dangerfield everybody there he
goes
goodbye rodney